الاوكراني بشكل عام كان يهيمن على كل
اعمال هذه القمه من انطلاقها ولكن ازداد
هذا الامر همم مع ضربات التي حدثت خلال
الساعات الماضيه سواء كذلك في اوكرانيا من
قبل روسيا او الصواريخ التي استهدفت او
سقطت في الاراضي البولنديه هذا الصباح
استيقظ احد عشر من القاده الموجودين هنا
في بالي وعقدوا اجتماعا طارق عنهم همم قاد
من الدول التي تنتمي الى مجموعه السبع
والى حل في شمال الاطلسي عقد اجتماع عن
طارق همم لبحث موضوع هذه الصواريخ التي
سقطت في بولندا على طبعا ان روسيا كان في
مسؤوليتها عن الامر تمكنا من ان نتحدث مع
مصدر مقرب من الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل اا
وقال لنا انه من المستبعد ان يقوم حلف
شمال الاطلسي بتفعيل الماده الخامسه
تحدثنا عن الماده الرابعه طبعا في هذه
النشره ولكن الماده الخامسه تنص على ان
الاعتداء على دوله من اعضاء حلف شمال
الاطلسي هي هو اعتداء على كل اعضاء هذا
الحلف هي ماده فعلت مره واحده في تاريخ
حلف شمال الاطلسي بعد اعتداءاته الحادي
عشر من ايلول سبتمبر في الولايات المتحده
همم من المستبعد اذن ان تقوم الدول
الاعضاء في حوشان الاساسيه اي رد عسكري ان
كان او ان همم صحه همم الشك بان روسيا هي
من وراء هذه همم الصواريخ التي سقطت
المسؤول المقرب من الرئيس الفرنسي يقول
لنا ان همم حلف شمال الاطلسي والدول
الغربيه بشكل عام تسعى الى تهدئه نحن لا
نريد الحرب مع روسيا ويمكننا ان نظهر
التضامن مع همم حلفائنا باشكال اخرى
مختلفه همم البيان الختامي اذا في هذه
القمه سوف يذكر كلمه اعتداء بالحديث
الغزو الروسي في اوكرانيا و ااا ينص
البيان على ان معظم اعضاء مجموعه العشرين
ينجدون بهذا الاعتداء الحديث طبعا عن معظم
اعضاء مجموعه العشرين يعني ان روسيا طبعا
بطبيعه الحال لا تؤيد هذا الكلام ولكن كان
من الممكن ان تقوم موسكو بالتحفظ على هذه
الجمله همم من الواضح حسب ما علمنا من
معلومات مقربه من الرئاسه الفرنسيه حتى
الان هو ان روسيا لم تتحفظ حتى على هذه
الجمله ولكن بكل الاحوال نحن نعلم ان همم
ممثل روسيا في هذه القمه وزير الخارجيه
غادر بالي منذ ليله امس